moi j'ai chiné delphine sur instagram
photo dc déjà envoyé les chevaux j'ai
tout envoyé
besoin de fait ce qu'on devait faire au
moins trois quatre mois quand elle s'est
pliée
mais pas seulement je suis
vraiment fier de toi pourquoi et parce
que c'est fort à le dire déjà assez fort
d'y croire
une photo qu'elle a dû mais djelic et
après le marais deux conditions un truc
comment tu vas et moi faut pas me dire
comment je vois
j'ai mangé des cailloux toute ma vie
enfoui la miss france qui me demande
comment je vais
envoyer trois coeurs direct non parce
que le producteur vraiment calé mission
d'apporter quelque chose de bien tu
avais des bonnes analyses et c'est ce
que je pense et ce que je pense toujours
d'ailleurs
c'est le papa delphine rouget enfin de
son vainqueur
mais il faudrait que tu reviennes si on
proposait de revenir wendy oui mais fera
que ce soit un peu plus différent sur la
que je parle plus je m'inquiète pas